president Trump's personal attorney
Michael Cohen would agree to a
deposition if a judge orders it that's
according to Cohen's attorney and
spokesman David Schwartz stormy Daniels
lawyer filed a motion yesterday seeking
to question mr. Trump and Cohen under
oath he wants to ask them at about a
$130,000 payment from Cohen to secure a
non-disclosure agreement with Daniel's
Daniel's claims she had sex with mr.
Trump in 2006 and argues the agreement
is not valid the White House has denied
Daniels allegations an attorney for the
president has not responded to our
request for comment David Schwartz is
with us now he is not representing Cohen
in this specific case but has been
authorized by Cohen to speak in his
defense good morning good morning I've
read much of what you've said you
acknowledge Michael Cohen is a quote
unquote fixer for Donald Trump is that
right he's absolutely a fixer that's
what he's been all along he's fixed all
kinds of problems for Donald Trump over
the years in fact he's the guy that you
called 3:00 in the morning when you have
a problem but it's not just for Donald
Trump it's for many people if I had a
problem I would call Michael Cohen at
3:00 in the morning because I know he
would do something stormy Daniels was
the problem so he fixed this on behalf
of Donald Trump he stormy Daniels was a
problem of course it's a problem when
anyone makes salacious accusations
that'll affect business that'll affect
reputation and that'll affect someone's
family so when this was brought to
Michael Cohen's attention and it was
brought to his attention okay a lawyer
for stormy Daniels called Michael Cohen
up and and he told Michael Cohen that it
would take a hundred and thirty thousand
dollars to solve the problem and Michael
Cohen entered into that it not only
affected business though it could have
affected the election it occurred that
this settlement occurred eleven days
before the election I know you say it's
not a campaign expense but it's a hell
of Anthony it could've would've
should've is not the standard of law in
this case okay there's got to be proof
and there's got to be a lot of proof
that somehow it was connected to the
election and there is no proof of that
and people enter into these agreements
every single day mr. Cohen handled other
agreements like this for mr. Trump me
mr. Cohen has handled all types
of things for mr. mr. Trump mr. cut has
he handled other agreements like this I
have no idea but he's handled all types
of items from mr. Trump's that would
cause a business problem for the company
and Michael Cohen had great lauded
latitude to handle those but David this
is a problem that keeps tripping people
up why would you pay a hundred why would
Michael Cohen pay a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars for something that
Donald Trump he's still not said I did
not have sex with that woman what what
happens at the White House is Sarah's
sander says that that White House says
that this has never happened but Donald
Trump himself has never personally
denied it so but still why do you pay a
hundred and thirty thousand fibers on
the dinner I understood be afraid to
love thought that says that's illogical
but when you're in business logic okay
but when you're in business and when
you're a politician or you're a lawyer
or you're a doctor and you're accused of
something and you have a decision to
make do I avoid litigation do I avoid
embarrassment can I have a
non-disclosure agreement signed and go
on with my life or am I going to enter
into a messy litigation I am going to
have a family problems there's gonna be
accusations all over the place it's
actually a no-brainer to enter into a
non-disclosure agreement and pay some
130-thousand why don't you guys call it
hush money right I call it legal
extortion because this happens every
single day that people come around
they're looking for a payout by the way
she really needed the money okay she was
desperate for the money she admitted on
60 minutes she was shopping the story
around everywhere she shopped the story
around then they went to Michael Cohen
and say hey give us $130,000 and we can
make this go away I'd like to get to the
legal question jor because you have said
that Donald Trump knew nothing about the
payment therefore the suggestion is that
that non-disclosure is not valid that
David Dennison the alias for Donald
Trump never signed it and as you know
Michael ammonite says therefore that NDA
is not valid
there's no I gotta get the suggestions
from Michael avenatti who has not come
through on anything yet he hasn't come
through on his polygraph test those CDs
that we saw in some safe he hasn't come
through on that he hasn't come
with anything the non-disclosure
agreement is rock-solid it's an
excellent non-disclosure agreement it's
a nondisclosure agreement between EC LLC
the the the LLC that was created by
Michael Cohen and stormy Daniels I and
the clause says and/or so even though
there was a line for day of adenosine
and or so it could be and/or the EC LLC
or David Dennis so you're saying it
doesn't matter that David Dennison
didn't sign but listen there is no
authority of the agreement there is no
love loss between you and Michael
avenatti and this is not an open
invitation let's start whacking at him
right right how do you see the two of
you see this actually resolving itself
look it's not my proudest moments when I
I know it's people saying it's great TV
but these are not my friends great he
called me a hack the other day right he
called me a hack on your show he must
have been referring to my representation
of New York City taxicabs fighting
against uber I'm not gonna stoop to his
level and call him names
you guys have called each other names we
I want to talk about something here
you've said that the president was not
aware of the agreement he was not aware
of the money right when did mr. Cohen
Cohen tell him about this or did he tell
him about it it the president became
aware of it much later on all right how
much later on I don't know he don't you
know Michael Cohen never told them about
it okay it didn't come out and it
learned about it from somewhere else he
learned about it when it came out before
they're like well the well she violated
the agreement right away right so she
never had any intention of so she stole
the hundred thirty thousand dollars
basically and then decided to shop the
story around but you know that so the
rumors got around Raymond you do see
that it defies logic knowing for anybody
who was worked with Donald Trump that he
would not know about this like he heard
about it Michael Cohen's not anyone
Michael Cohen's not anyone he's a very
loyal trusted person who had great
latitude to be the fixer and that's
exactly what he was he was the fixer and
he took out a home equity loan in order
to pay off stormy deals to get the money
quickly does that make sense to you that
a lawyer would take out a home equity
loan of the owner in a van
that makes sense in a vacuum No would I
do that no for an outside client it's a
different you have to understand it's a
different relationship between these two
people that's what I'm trying it is not
a lawyer-client relationship I the way
he wasn't acting for Donald David
Denison he was acting for you realize
there are tackle stations for you
legally he will yes taxable what are the
tax implications for stormy does she
receive the money right a lot does
Donald Trump need a lot of fixing they
need a lot I think that I think anyone
in the line of fire with a high profile
needs fixing I think I think I think
it's very clear anyone running for
election needs fixing to look this is
this is a slippery slope so any business
transaction that takes place while
anyone's running for election whether
it's Congress yeah US Senate you're
gonna analyze every single transaction
that's a slippery slope to say oh that
must be a campaign contribution that is
guesswork that's speculation and that
really should have no place in federal
elections Normie Daniels has filed a
defamation suit against Michael Cole
because he called her a liar how does he
whoa whoa is that the statement is that
did he call her a liar in that this is
DC it's another avenatti okay guy a lot
of credit he puts these thoughts in
people's minds if you look at this
statement he said he said whether or not
something is true or not true it could
still affect a person and I will do
anything in my power to protect Donald
Trump that was that was the statement so
when you're doing a defamation case and
I'm bringing a defamation case on behalf
of Michael Cohen against BuzzFeed so
when you're doing a defamation case you
got to analyze the statement and you got
to ask yourself the key element is the
statement false so how is that statement
false that case is going to be dismissed
right away right on the face of it we
are at a timetable thank you so much we
had more time okay yes thank you thanks
a lot thanks David
yes come back and see us I will because
this story is not going away thank you
David for goddes very much